if an ancient civilization in Earth's
history had made geostationary
satellites would they still be in orbit
today yes there is nothing to to
interfere with the orbit of a
geostationary satellite it is it is so
far out
orbiting 22,000 miles above Earth's
surface
mm-hmm but would that be in kilometers I
guess eight that's unbelievably wrong
let's try 30,000 no yeah about 30,000
kilometers up you if you're that high up
there are no air molecules from our
atmosphere to slow you down and decay
your orbit and drop you into the Pacific
Ocean or anywhere else
so yes it'll stay it's basically we'll
stay in orbit around the Earth forever
unless some asteroid or the meteor hits
it and but that would be an
extraordinary fact with the dynamics are
stable we're good but that would not be
for me the most interesting fact here it
would be that we had civilization that
had made that it sent something into
space and we haven't found them right
and then where are they you know are the
underground so I would be way more
impressed
so people that such a civilization
existed then that they put up a
spacecraft right all right